Brad Pitt's continuing his celebratory
summer taking his bullet train press
splits to Asia but unfortunately the
Oscar winner couldn't escape two major
dramas from his past that are
resurfacing
not even a 53-page FBI document Leak
with allegations of a drunken mid-flight
fight could put Brad in a bad mood he
was all smiles and being silly in South
Korea with his bullet train co-star
Aaron Taylor-Johnson
there's nothing simple about this job
while Brad continues his promotional
tour behind the scenes he's doing good
remember the houses he helped build in
New Orleans after Hurricane Katrina will
Brad help coordinate a 20.5 million
dollar resolution to the lawsuit that
will allow the community to finally
rebuild I was with Brad in New Orleans
in 2007 at the start of the project he
was passionate about helping Families in
Need You know in a tragedy like this you
know we're supposed to help the most
vulnerable there's people on the ground
here that are that are trying to rectify
that moving on to a different kind of
rebuild NeNe Leakes is showing us the
before and after of her plastic surgery
I feel absolutely great at the arrival
section 360 in a professional mini not a
big booty girl mini BBL the 54 year old
former Real Housewives of Atlanta Star
documented the process and says she only
wanted to fix some problem areas I felt
like I had a bra role you know you women
know what I'm talking about and then
after that back we started talking about
uh what we're gonna put this fat at
right that you taking out of my body I
have no problem I represent the full
fine women not the full figure women the
full fine women that means I'm fine I
have a small waist and hips and all that
I'm with men like though so why just a
mini Brazilian butt lift I just think
that
the old folks home many years from now
are gonna look crazy everybody with
giant booties up in there
[Music]
thank you
foreign